the screen credit a film by has added
resonance this year in four out of five
films directed by men who wrote their
screenplays the fifth is a veteran
director whose to previous Oscars
validate his habit of making outstanding
films the nominees for best achievement
in directing are Anthony Minghella for
the English Patient
joel coen for Fargo Milosh Foreman for
the People vs Larry Flynt Mike Lee for
secrets and lies scott hicks for shine
and Oscar goes to Anthony Minghella hood
English Patient
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's my daughter's 18th birthday today
happy birthday and thanks to all my
family who put up with me being away for
so long
my wife has taught me the meaning of the
word eggs aureus this is belongs to a
lot of people whose shoulders I've been
standing on for the last four and a half
years I thank them all the real
international sand club the main
directors as we called them thanks to
all of them thanks to my agents Michael
Preston and Julia - thanks to the whole
crew - ray Fiennes Kristin Scott Thomas
Willem Dafoe Juliet Naveen Colin all the
people who made this possible - Bob and
Harvey Weinstein and all the great team
in Miramax bless you guys thank you very
much indeed and thank you to to my
partner in crime sores ants it's a great
day for the Isle of Wight today thank
you very much
[Music]
Oh